We actually have some good news to start with
today.
Obviously, this is a context of lots of really
bad news, but it seems as though Dr. Anthony
Fauci is completely outrageous and adversarial.
Relationship with the White House is going
to be repaired the day that President elect
Joe Biden is sworn in just six and a half
weeks from now, because we've learned that
Joe Biden spoke to Dr. Fauci and has first
and foremost confirmed that Dr. Fauci, Joe
Biden wants Dr. Fauci to stay in his role
at the NIH as the head essentially the the
the head of of fighting pandemics as the case
effectively is in the United States.
And in addition to this, Joe Biden has offered
Dr. Anthony Fauci the role of chief medical
adviser to the White House.
And Dr. Fauci says that he accepted this offer
on the spot.
Here is video of Anthony Fauci being interviewed
on NBC by Savannah Guthrie.
They also spoke about 100 day masking campaign,
which Joe Biden has already asked Dr. Fauci
about.
And I want to talk about that as well.
So let's take a look at this clip.
Joe Biden said in an interview yesterday on
his inauguration he's going to ask Americans
to wear a mask for one hundred days.
He said just one hundred days, not forever.
Is that enough or do you feel like that might
put an artificial time limit on how long people
may need to be wearing masks?
No, no, he didn't mean it that way.
I spoke to him about that.
What he wants, he just wants to get and it's
a good idea uniform.
He's saying, hey, folks, trust me, everybody,
for 100 days now, it might be that after that,
we still going to need it.
But he just wants it everybody for a commitment
for 100 days.
And I discussed that with him and I told him
I thought that was a good idea.
He also said when he spoke to you, he asked
you to continue in your role, which you've
had under six presidents, but also to serve
as his chief medical adviser.
Will you do that?
Did you say?
Yes.
Oh, absolutely, I said yes, right on the spot.
Yeah, we have to hope that the combination
of the vaccine starting to roll out, although
likely a bit of a slower rollout than we would
like a combined with sanity entering the White
House, combined with hopefully better treatments
becoming available.
We are hoping that this will give us a much
better march than we are likely to see in
January and February.
And then hopefully this will give us a better
second quarter of twenty twenty one than we
are likely to see in the first quarter of
twenty twenty one.
And then hopefully we will have a better second
half of twenty twenty one than what the first
half will be.
But let's talk briefly about this 100 day
mask thing.
I talked about this yesterday during during
a live stream a little bit.
This is already being framed as some kind
of right wing authoritarian nightmare police
state where Joe Biden is deploying federal
troops to force people to wear masks.
Now, I want to remind you, the authoritarian
nightmare is Trump and Trump's leaving.
It was Trump who used the military for domestic
law enforcement and sent the military into
protests that was authoritarian.
It's Trump who claims he won an election that
he lost.
That's authoritarian.
It's Trump who has been attacking a free press
and attacking individual journalists.
That's authoritarian.
And I could go on.
Joe Biden can't actually effect a massive
mandate.
Don't forget this.
When we hear about Joe Biden will ask all
Americans to wear a mask, that's literally
what it will be.
He will ask Americans to wear a mask.
He can also and will ask governors to push
mask wearing and put in place mask mandates,
at least from the standpoint of commerce and
businesses.
Joe Biden cannot legally put in place a mask
mandate.
So everybody's saying the mask mandate he
will put in is authoritarian.
He will not because he cannot put in place
a mask mandate.
Now, lots of people will ignore it.
Hopefully many won't and will be able to work
together to reduce the number of cases and
the number of deaths as we start to vaccinate
people, hopefully as soon as a week from today.
But the big story is Dr. Fauci staying on
and getting a bigger role.
Government living in reality is going to come
back.
We really need that desperately.
We also need to be revering the doctors that
are spending their careers trying to keep
people healthy.
Under Trump.
Dr. Fauci started to need full time armed
security for himself and for his family.
This is not normal.
That's insanity.
There are very sick people in this country
that made armed security a necessity for Dr.
Fauci.
We have to reverse that now.
Now, you might be wondering, why would Joe
Biden do this?
Isn't Joe Biden worried and jealous that Anthony
Fauci might end up with a higher approval
rating than Joe Biden?
And the answer is no, we're not worried about
that.
Joe Biden is not going to determine which
doctors he hires based on whether they have
higher or lower approvals.
Remember Donald Trump complaining at a rally
and at press briefings that somehow Foushee
has a higher approval rating than Trump has?
We've had terrible luck, really.
It's really Dr. Fowkes, bad luck when we needed
him the most and not that we didn't need him
during Ebola, not that we didn't need Foushee
during HIV and SARS.
We did.
But when we needed Foushee the most during
a global hundred year pandemic, we have a
president who doesn't listen to Fauci and
actually attacks Foushee to such a degree
that Fauci needs armed security.
It's truly insane.
The good news is that at least this aspect
of the insanity of this administration is
going
to
be reversed.